are you kidding me
no seriously you got to come back with
the ball right now you'll come back and
now
i don't even know claire yeah i'm sorry
you left her jacket yeah well when did
you give it to your new fat uncle
girlfriend
i didn't even met her yet whatever you
left your jacket me gage
throw it in a river why would i do that
i don't care i'm over it
fine
good
me give me a lounge get your jacket
though
seriously vegan you start buying drinks
for everybody as soon as she comes
over i mean who does that you didn't
come back to the bar
you're literally an [ __ ] how is that
possible i can't be an [ __ ] i got
arms and legs and a head
where's my jacket i have your jacket
do you want it no you know what eat it
why would i do that you know what
i'm not following you anymore fine
me didn't come back to the bar yeah me
yet
now be good
negan do you want your jacket
no seriously come back to the bar
you go back to the bar i'm gonna throw
this jacket in the water
oh nice that's really nice what do you
want me to do megan
damn kiss my butthole okay good fine
fine then i'm going i'm leaving right
now
god damn it
reagan no like seriously your jacket
yeah but it's your jacket though
[Music]
me again no
i have your i have your jacket
i'm over it seriously me
[Music]
you